I think that I just think it's better
for the kids to spend more time with the
mother and I think if that's through
homeschooling I think that's what we
should be pushing is the mom to be home
but what about the rest of the family
though because you know it takes a
village to raise a child right um about
the rest of the family so mum's at work
it's at work but you've got Grandma and
all of these people at home yeah I think
those are great I think we should be
pushing the grandparents too but at the
end of the day a lot of times like
parents will will put off their decision
and have their grandparents watch them
what it's like it's not their kid right
and I think I think that we should push
the mom to stay home as much as possible
or work from home yeah I mean the good
thing about it these days is that we
have that flexibility we can work yeah
I'm saying you know I think both can be
done to be honest look